I recently moved to Manchester and a
good friend of mine came up to visit me
and we decided we were going to go out
in town went a few bars and a few clubs
and then when we left the final Club we
got separated I didn't have my phone on
me so I can contact him either I met a
group of people and they asked me to go
for a nightcap with them I went back to
what I later found out was a hotel room
with them I had a few drinks and then
everyone else bar two and left those two
them started taking it upon themselves
to rape me
while it was going on I just tried to
block out what was happening he kinda
fight flight or flop and in that
situation I've loved which to some
people means you laid there let it
happen but if you've been for a
situation it means it's just whether
you're polish react is a natural
reaction and you're just trying to block
out what's actually happened to you at
the time I was still with it to a
certain extent I still remember a lot
more like the conversations and things
that we had until I had the final
drinking dish with those two and then my
memory goes really hazy and then to me
that leads to believe that I was right
first thing I remember is the arches on
Bell Street car park I then walked back
to my flat and as a walk back I was
still in shock there was until I came to
the bridge which is close to where I
lived and if any kind ball hit me and
then I decided that you know what I
started think I didn't want to live with
this isn't there what I wanted to do and
if it wasn't for the thought of what
would my family friends the devastation
would have been I would have jumped off
that bridge but I continued walking back
and then I met my girlfriend at the time
my best friend in the flat and then this
men at war Fedora burst into tears I
didn't know what to do the only thing
that they could think of was that needs
more importance at least straight away
whereas all I wanted to do was have a
shower and get the smell of these people
off me when I reported to the police the
initial response wasn't the greatest I'm
not going to lie and I felt I wasn't
believed in that situation I guess they
let they do post judgment where they
probably shouldn't and without dealing
with males as often as they are doing
the females maybe they haven't got the
same level of compassion as they would I
found out about survivors Manchester
from the ops that took me to st. Mary's
and it was it was perfect in every way
when it came to providing support I
needed the clinical therapy is
one-on-one so you would go there and sit
with the therapist and talk at your own
pace but you can talk about your
feelings how it made you feel
what the hell after words how you've
tried to deal with it and also they can
give you things like grounding
techniques mindfulness which means
you can go about your normal life I'm
not talking about it in front of Allah
in which I thinks what a lot of men do
in this situation I really hadn't held
myself within a month or two of talking
to a therapist and so it can be more
open with my friends and family I
started to feel better and I felt that
so many of the men will be in this
situation that maybe if I was to go out
and talk about it in a national level
then it would have helped other men that
were struggling to approach their
friends and family or approaching
therapists talked about it as well it
meant I could turn the big negative into
a positive
initially I wasn't nervous about today
that that's not I've seen but that first
gig would it being so close to home runs
that's close there was a venue that I
knew it made it a lot easier for me to
do that and DJ something that I've
always loved it's always been a big
passion of mine and you can get yourself
lost in the moment you just play any
music concentrate on what you're doing
you don't concentrate on the nightlife
and the scene around you by doing this
mix then I hope that I can and raise
money for spiders Manchester and I also
hope I can help other people to come
forward I'd also want to raise awareness
of male rape in general before this
happened to me I never thought of it
happens males that's the same thoughts
that my friends my family had had as
well in the world we live in abortion
that we all need to keep ourselves safe
it doesn't mean that we can't go out and
get driven to can't go out have a good
time but it just means names keeping
friends playing she needs make sure
you've got contacts make sure you've got
a home and then
strangers
[Music]
you